So today we've discussed how to plan out actions using formal logic.
We started off by talking about states, operators, and goals in formal logic.
We then used those to contextualize our discussion on detecting conflicts that
might arise. This introduced the need for
partial-order planning which helps us avoid those conflicts beforehand.
Finally we talked about hierarchical tasks networks which can be used for
hierarchical planning. Now, we're going to move on to understanding,
which builds on our notion of frames from a few lessons ago, but if you're
interested in this, you can jump forward to our lessons on design. Configuration
and diagnosis leverage some of the concepts of planning very heavily.